وقود بشري في الحرب غير مكلف سياسيا يلجا
اليه نتنياهو وسط شكوك في تواطؤ
[موسيقى]
غربي كيف تستفيد اسرائيل من
المرتزقه كما يزداد الاعتقاد لدى مجاهدينا
بان العدو يستخدم مرتزقه خلال عمليته التي
يدعي انها حرب وجود وكرامه وطنيه اعتماد
اسرائيل على المرتزقه يعود الى النكبه عام
1948 اذ استاجرت عشرات الامريكيين
والفرنسيين والاسباني والاوكراني للقتال
الى جانب العصابات الصهيونيه ضد
الفلسطينيين وبحسب بيانات رسميه حديثه
للكنيست استعانت اسرائيل باكثر من
5500 مرتزق سنويا بين عامي 2002
و22 وفي حرب
2014 وحدها استاجرت نحو 6000 مرتزق وفق
تقرير للمرصد الاور متوسطي لحقوق الانسان
وخلال العدوان الحالي على غزه ظهرت ادله
كثيره على وجود المرتزقه منها هذا الفيديو
لمقاتلين يتحدثون اللغه الاوكرانيه في احد
الازقه في غزه بعد اصابه
[موسيقى]
احدهم وسبق ان تداول ناشطون مقاطع لمرت
اخرين يعترفون بقتال حماس بينهم جنود
سابقون في قوات المارينز الامريكيه بحسب
صحيفه الموندو
الاسبانيه
مع تصاعد الخسائر في صفوف جيش الاحتلال في
اخر اسبوعين كشف لاول مره عن مقتل سبعه
مرتزقه اوكرانيين في حي الشجاعيه واثارت
وسائل اعلام غربيه القضيه على نحو واسع
فكشف تحقيق كل شبكه اوروبا واحد عن وجود
4185 مرتزقا فرنسيا في غزه وهي ثاني اكبر
جنسيه اجنبيه بعد الولايات المتحده واثار
ذلك مطالبات في البرلمان الفرنسي بسحب
الجنسيه من مزدوجي الجنسيه اذا ثبت انهم
قاتلوا في صفوف الجيش
الاسرائيلي وفي اسبانيا كشف عن استعانه تل
ابيب بجيش صغير من المرتزقه الاسبان مقابل
3900 يورو في الاسبوع الواحد قابله
للزياده اما جنوب افريقيا فاعلنت الحكومه
فتح تحقيقات قضائيه لملاحقه المواطنين
والمقيمين ممن يثبت عملهم مرتزقه لاسرائيل
اسرائيل لا تنفي ولا تؤكد مشاركه مرتزقه
في الحرب الحاليه لكنها تسمح لهم الادلاء
بتصريحات في الاعلام الغربي على عكس
جنودها النظاميين وذلك بهدف تشجيع اليهود
في العالم على المشاركه في
الحرب فماذا تستفيد اسرائيل من المرتزقه
رغم وجود جيش نظامي ونحو
360 الف جندي احتياط يرى خبراء ان وجود
المرتزقه يقلل عدد القتلى المعلن لجنود
الجيش ومن ثم تجنب اثاره غضب الراي العام
الداخلي ويسمح بتسريح عدد اكبر من جنود
الاحتياط للعوده الى وظائفهم المدنيه
وتقليل الخسائر الاقتصاديه اما تغطيه
نفقات المرتزقه فتكون عبر منح سخيه من
الولايات المتحده او من تبرعات اليهود في
[موسيقى]
العالم a